good morning morning millennial how was
everyone doing today
we're good it's the last day you'll see
me as a 25 year old so take a good hard
look okay make it good and make it hard
it's migraine season out there today is
it yeah this is like full migraine
weather when the weather is gray I can
feel it I woke up with a heavy head and
I didn't know why and then I opened my
blinds and like oh I'm getting a
migraine today oh wow well I had no clue
was raining because I don't open my
blinds anyway I never know what the
weather is do you see my story I asked
Alexa Alexa whatsoever because I could
tell there was a great gonna set off
everyone oh god I could tell there was a
greatness in me in the air so I was like
potential it could be raining
I'll ask Alexa Alexa what's the weather
she says it's 50 degrees today's
forecast calls for a high of 60 a low of
50 maybe he'll be the high we saw with
rain just [ __ ] tell me it's raining
like that sounds helpful no I didn't
know that when I sent outside it's gonna
be raining like that sounds like it's
going to rain today right right no it
should she needs to say hello good
morning it is raining
grab an umbrella or soon they ran out in
the rain
almost got hate time across the street
and I like I know the driver for the car
they don't like I wasn't sure because
like please you're going like one mile
an hour they don't try to kill me
drivers day is route of course of course
there's nothing like as a pedestrian
ruing a drivers day you know those are
my favorite things to do in Manhattan
but you can also be a driver and ruin
pedestrians day okay wait I have to tell
you literally the most amazing thing
actually I want to say guys I don't want
to put like shed light on it but this
person like this obviously like mean
like guy on Twitter like when I read
about me and I always search myself like
on Twitter saying wow you it's like it's
no don't get me wrong there was a four
month period where I never did it but
now it's just back to like no but even
still like I Google myself like all the
time like what pictures were taken of me
like you know at an event that I didn't
see right um but Twitter is just like
you know it's a brave thing but I really
do feel like I want to be in tune with
what my haters are saying about me so if
they're making valid points I can think
just you know I'm not unrealistic and
this guy went on it's like this threat
it was just like it wasn't mean it was
like catty [ __ ] like literally being
like I guess I don't even remember
saying this because I have to mention
but he was like one time I heard girls
no job interview station
the Carrie Bradshaw of the digital age
and I just never forgave her for it and
honestly I agree
like I don't even remember saying that I
think it was Nightline I remember that
sounds familiar
I was just trying to relate to the old
people who were watching Nightline I'm
like they're like what are you do I'm
like oh I write on Instagram right the
Carrie Bradshaw of the digital age I
don't actually think that cuz I'm
annoying and like I don't own BB Manolo
Blahnik heels but the thread was really
mean but he made some valid points that
is so funny and that wasn't before you
three watch Sex in the City of me and we
learned the truth that's Rebecca and I
was just a young and who thought Carrie
Bradshaw was a good representation for
women and now you're really the Miranda
of the digital age I completely agree
and you know what I think that's a
compliment you know actually a while
back back when I was a blogger I did a
whole in-depth analysis on the
characters of Sex in the City before we
watching it in full and I just have to
say I was very in tune because I said
that like calling someone the Miranda
used to be a wild insult but like
homegirl is the only one in touch with
reality over there and yes she's a
little cynical and her haircuts annoying
but like lest we not forget the the
kitten heel of it all you know I agree I
mean you don't want to be the carrier
you don't wanna be the Miranda like for
me I think Samantha made the show so yes
but you also like you don't want to be
this man that you don't wanna be the
shucks I mean they all kind of stuff but
I love Samantha and Charlotte I do they
could have their own spin-off I'd be
happy with that
except they like in the show weren't
really raised so because they have
nothing in common yeah they're just too
too different yeah I watched so much TV
this weekend we're gonna recap all that
so much to talk about
I feel like Desperate Housewives
although it's amazing has really gotten
me like off my game when it comes to my
TV schedule and I went in bed last night
you feel like that's one the fault of
Desperate Housewives into the content
that's out there because when something
needs to be watched you watch it when
Maroney was like really polarizing that
is the conversation in this country like
we were on top of it totally it really
was I completely know nothing like that
is happening with OC or Dallas knows why
we are not inclined to keep up with it
the only thing you need to know is that
I don't give a rip what do you do
exactly
so last night like I got into bed and I
didn't even know because I never watched
cable in my bedroom that it doesn't even
work like I had to get on the phone with
the cable company like it was okay I
made that cable company all right by the
way you really do have to mention
because you've told us that before oh
whatever I'm this here show so I fixed
it and I got in bed and I watched all
the programs like I'm halfway by the end
of this week I will be back on blueblood
Riverdale dynasty Dallas OC Kardashians
lady gang and because I had so many
thoughts I don't wanna talk about it
upsetting that that's part with your run
man now oh well it has to be and okay
should we just talk about it yeah yeah
we're gonna talk about it I don't know
we usually save our TV cups for that but
we have Margaret Joseph's here today no
one's heard up at the past tide we got a
whisk her off okay so let's just art
with Kardashians it was a good episode
like they obviously ended it right
before the actual like good part and
they they promoted it as like this is
the episode know some me for me finding
out how they found out and how they
communicated it to Chloe was the good
part yes another Kardashian birth this
will now be the oak nines I'm I'm cool
with I can wait until next week but like
seeing how angry Kim was and like how no
one knew what to do and how they had to
hold her back and like even like just
the way people were talking about it
Scott was like you're literally she's
about to pop off like why are you out in
these streets but once I didn't address
the what's that the video was from
October no the first video that came out
was from the night before and then TMZ
released a video from October that they
had since October but didn't release
because Kris like Kris once it was out
there that Tristan was cheating on Chloe
TMZ didn't care and it's actually really
interesting how Kim said so many people
like King to her more like oh I knew
this and I heard this cuz you know what
it like it's always like when something
like when someone gets accused of sexual
assault like if a million people come
out it's like you know that it's a limit
claim but if it's like a one-off it's
like mmm so you know that like twisted
was to not that he's a sexual assault or
I'm just using reference of like when it
rains Newark and Kim was like when
there's one picture one video like it
can be taken out of context you can kind
of explain like you have you have
pictures worth a thousand degrees you
know it could be something else but when
there's multiple instances of proof it's
over so I really did feel like the
episode delivered and and the logistics
of it all like them getting on the plane
to Chris and the guy no make it today
fly commercial no there's no way are you
sure because I thought the same thing
they went from LAX no I think that um
probably planes can fly in Talia no but
it wasn't even that oh maybe that was it
yeah yeah cuz they flew from LAX they
flew from Van Nuys I mean I just had a
million thoughts I'm like their land was
so stupid to have the doctor be in LA I
didn't know that until Chris said I'm
supposed to bring the doctor I'm like
what first of all her being in Cleveland
was so stupid cuz he wasn't even in
Cleveland it was
Milica in this big house and that guy
stabbed downstairs no but Tristan was
supposed to be in Cleveland and when I
think what he was an away games right no
but when he came home then she kicked
him out he had know for sure for sure
but like if he was coming home from an
away game why couldn't he just come to
LA and then also I think she wanted to
give birth in Cleveland cuz where you
give birth is where you have to spend
the next few months like oh right and
she wanted to be in Cleveland even
though she really should have given
birth in LA but hindsight is 2012 antara
bilang xiety for I'm like I can't
imagine being alone especially like for
like a family who's so family-oriented
like being alone sucks and then like
being alone when you're literally about
to give birth also sucks and being alone
when your life is falling apart ain't go
to and it's like you can't drink or take
a xanax also but I thought Kim did end
up going to her reunion ski-doos okay so
I've been playing I've been looking at
the dates of this Khloe's expected
delivery date was the 14th she wound up
giving birth on Wednesday the 11th and
Kim's reunion was on Friday so that's so
13th I think Kim goes to the birth on
Wednesday makes it for the birth is
there Thursday goes to her reunion on
Friday and maybe comes back to clean got
it got it
um which is like all she wanted to do
and that's so funny he's like I waited
20 years for this reunion and then Chloe
was worse and they're like both too
immovable things right no that's that is
truly life but if I were to kim
kardashian like there's nothing I would
want more than to go to my 20-year
reunion like hey [ __ ] what family
like you thought I had a unibrow in high
school yeah here I hate the literary she
opens the door hey [ __ ] what's up
totally also when Kendall and Scott
we're going skydiving me and Margo were
freaking I was freaking out that was
like the one that was my of all the
things that happened at this episode
that was my most visceral reaction to
something I was when she was there
walked off like limped off she like just
gave when they said you're suspending
through air for eight minutes I'm like
does your belly stop dropping eventually
like I guess so and honestly not that I
ever plan on never but really I would
have been the same as Hannah like I did
I actually would have shat my pants in
addition I said there's a man attached
to your back because I wouldn't go I
would need someone to just push me out
of there right and then she used do see
she starts having fun like it's it's
just to become fine see what I said was
so relatable she was like you go through
so many emotions it's probably like the
eight minutes you do the drop you're
like what the
am i doing and they're like oh this
isn't so bad and then you realize again
you're like above like [ __ ] grass and
you're like wait no this sucks I'm
afraid I hated my life and love everyone
like I understood the emotion of it all
but I'm sorry I just cuz let me and
Margaret talking about it she was like I
would do it like I would never yeah
for so many reasons like I have no
desire to feel like what it feels like
to jump out of a plane like I'm good
just sitting in first class don't mind
me to that plane and you know that the
Kardashians did it like in the most
upscale a a plus first-class way like
that was the best most safe company like
that plane looked like it was made out
of a paper plate and when they opened
that little garage in the back of the
plane I was just not here for it like
the whole thing I don't test god like
that like to me it's like you obviously
like want to die like I have no desire
to die I have no desire I love my life I
have a son there are so many things that
I can do being someone who's scared of
everything to get that sort of thrill
you know even a haunted house would
would fix me right up I mean agree you
know so it was well but Scott saying and
this has been my theory that everyone on
planes should have a parachute so that
if the plane goes down you can just jump
out that's I feel like such an amazing
idea but then someone messaged me saying
that commercial planes fly too high and
too fast but eventually they go slow and
low if it's going down right right right
I guess like when you're coming out of a
plane you're not really jumping out of
like the sky like you do on a commercial
flight right yeah hearing a guy like
went to the moon and jumped out what
yeah I don't know yeah yeah like a
couple Felix his name was Felix and he
was sponsored by Red Bull and yes I
remember
ya know he was like a paraglider like a
jumper for a he jumps for a living I
don't know he would jump off the
mountains like into the clouds yeah and
to be jumped from above the clouds like
off a planet into the world sure I think
he's just off like a hot really high
mountain no no no it was in the galaxy
okay okay no I definitely jumped like
from atmosphere I'm cooling I'm googling
Felix the jumper redbull they should
make a movie you know and he went
unconscious during the jump because it's
like so high and he eventually woke up
cuz it was like a 10-minute fall Felix
yeah okay what's that you guys yeah he
was in the Earth's orbit that is so look
at this picture he's literally outside
earth oh my god I want a thumb and how
do they figure out where he was gonna
land like that's what I was struggling
with with Kendall - I'm like how do you
know that guy was really trustworthy
when he said he's been doing this 40
years and like he just he was honest
he's has a few sprained ankle
Ike if I ever saw him out of a plane I
would go with him of quit his company
because I really liked his honesty you
know but I am never like that just
cemented for me I was having such a
rollercoaster of emotions for her but
sometimes they do such dumb [ __ ] on the
show like when they go TV till I get
their blood rushing but like this I was
really heavily invested in the AG being
I was like that does not look like fun
all I could think of is how much I was
sweating that looks like fun for me like
that seeks when they were like this did
nothing for me I was like perfect I
prefer snowmobiling I think it's really
the same thing except with dirt you know
it's a sweat and that's why I'm not
interested okay they were like in the
desert anyways Kardashians are just
really giving it to us this season yes
so that was a premium episode I love
just like the sisterly like oh my god
they can't get their schedule together
they get they can't get their two
schedules together for a photo shoot but
like someone gets cheated on and they
drop everything and they pack up their
suitcase and they got Lee yeah I loved
it and also the Brown University class I
can't believe I didn't go to brown like
I can't believe it no okay it's not one
of those girls on the Skype is a toaster
yeah I was thinking this he was [ __ ]
failed us and they were reacting just as
I wanted them to like him Kim came they
ride a Nazi they should have had
Kourtney come first cuz like it was like
Kim came in and Kourtney came like no
guys no but like and I love Chris for
doing I'm so here for the Kardashians
being you know an important thing to
study and an important figure and that's
what the girl said you were these
polarizing figures in pop culture but
like this is an Ivy League education
that's all I'm saying I am receiving an
Ivy League education by watching
Kardashian news apparently you know if
you are studying in an Ivy League school
and you're studying media you like the
Kardashians are a part of that
conversation regardless if you hate them
or if you like them for sure but it was
a class on just Kardashian like yeah I
like if I can check because honestly
like a recitation subclass with a
know-it-all take it round is a really
weird school because they have like
classes on astrology right no they're so
like free liberating the Brill
like liberal arts II and it's like you
can literally make up a class and it's a
credit yeah that's right I'm not you're
like want to go to brown yeah it's
really hard to get in but once you're
there it's like keeping up smooth sailin
so then let's talk about the programming
that lets you load busy busy Phillips
busy tonight and I've restrained from
saying anything because I haven't seen
the show right and I really do want a
show to do well when the person who got
the show got it because they have a
funny Instagram like hello yeah I'm here
for it
and I just have to say it is not good
and before everyone comes for me it's
like Busy Philipps has been now
categorized by society as like you can't
say anything bad about her because she's
a woman of a certain age I don't know
why she's not protected she's being
protected and if you say anything she
she's like she's 40 if you say anything
about her show you don't support women
like that is the narrative now where
it's like no no I'm not gonna support
her show just because she's a woman that
would be putting her at a major
disadvantage and making her think that
her saying um for 30 minutes straight is
good content right in the show okay so
here's where the show doesn't I don't
jive with the show so she does this like
intro monologue Fast Five like whatever
she breezes is too fast it's too fast
it is scripted because she is glaring at
the teleprompter so she loves to go
off-book and she's not good at it no so
she keeps having to go back on script
and she's like um and she doesn't know
how to transition but I think the
off-book moments a lot of them are also
scripted she has her three writers in
the front row what the hell is that I
don't know there's that one writer who
looks like she does not want to be there
and half way on the right yes again
Hathaways yeah she does not want to be
there um I watched his first episode
yesterday morning like just to see
because the toasters had a lot to say
about it is it live I think it's films
like in the afternoon because she did
talk about her day earlier that day and
never Charlie Roberts I thought it was
live the whole time because she was
doing a bad job and I'm like they would
have edited better but then Julia
Roberts was like I heard that this our
interview is gonna be on TV later I
think it's like the kimmells like the
Jimmy's it's in the afternoon and I
don't think they edited that much unless
something crazy were to happen so our
complaint all the time is like that
these a shows are way too structured
like they need every 10 seconds be like
let's play a game this is our section oh
now we're gonna go to commercial right
and it's like you know what I couldn't
used a little bit more of that with busy
because it was too free-balling and
she's not there yet to be like good at
transitions with the cameras and the
teleprompter it's just um
um I mean never taking our shoes off and
putting on an icon and this song oh my
god this song then I was watching as I
wound down last night and Busy Philipps
sang me to sleep Zach came in and was
like oh she's trying me mr. Rodgers
before he puts his shoes on and I was
like what are you talking okay there's a
lot of - where's she going I realized
I've never I don't know mr. Rodgers I've
never seen mr. Rodgers I think any time
anyone with reference mr. Rodgers I just
pretended like I knew but I'm here to
say who the [ __ ] is mr. Rodgers I don't
know it's before our time and now it's
coming back because Tom Hanks is playing
him in a movie and he was from
Pittsburgh
so like when the Pittsburgh thing how
many people were like quoting him I
don't know I have no idea who he said I
think she took she just taken from mr.
Rodgers a song before bedtime while she
puts her nightgown down know what mr.
obviously alive during this like pure
time or like people like to be son to
sleep I don't if don't don't sing us to
sleep in 2018 if you don't want to be
made fun of I'm sorry no like actually
I'm in town for the singing nice to
sleep she is a really nice kid a nice
voice yeah and that's the way she like
looks at the note right it's just like I
don't I'm not feeling it and I guess the
mr. nightgown is - no - mr. Rodgers I
don't know this is all speculation but
it just wasn't working for me that's
just proof that E is like not in tune
because they're trying so hard to reach
the Millennial audience we don't know
who mr. Rogers is so if you're gonna
make references explain them like yeah
and I could watch the first episodes
like that like I understood like the
structure you know yeah so I just came
in like eyes wide open I had no idea
which is what probably most people who
land on the show do so they should
really like especially in the beginning
make it more clear like what the [ __ ] is
going on and we're here to kill world
hangout this is safe space I'm like I
don't feel safe when I just like don't
think it's going well for you right and
you know what she's doing a lot of the
times it's something I used to do during
my shows when I was like very
uncomfortable in my own skin and like
not sure if it was going well I would
ask the audience questions like are we
having fun you know what I owe
everything good Jedi you know like and
she kept throwing to the audience
where's like they don't even have a
microphone so we can't even hear what
they say but like I just know that that
I was using Mister Rogers is all
Millennials maybe it's just us nobody we
didn't get that channel no clue who mr.
Rogers is yeah it's definitely just us
just like I don't know that we watch so
much bill I know that my friends have no
idea who
Roger says maybe it's at like not a
Jewish thing maybe but Zack now oh he
did yeah he was like she ideally been
would know - I'm gonna okay we need to
take a poll magnify our house kinda
that's why I was I waited to admit it
until right now that I don't know how
mr. Rogers is because you know who mr.
Rogers was they everyone definitely does
I think it's just is em well whatever
regardless the show is just not working
for me for so many reasons
and like the interview with Julia
Roberts was like literally like bizzy's
Bat Mitzvah she was being busy was being
Hoda like making an interview about
someone else about herself right and
it's like how much are we gonna talk
about Instagram as much as I love doing
Roberts and I think she's like the most
beautiful person on planet and she was
so cool and she did a good job she has a
20 answer sister she was pulling the
interview like you never seen her
Instagram in my entire life but Jackie
do you know that Julia Roberts Instagram
is the microwave grandma thing the story
about Natalie Portman like helps her get
on Instagram right using it I felt like
my name is in the microwave Izzie said
Julia joined in June 2018 and and I
choked in February oh yeah great choking
okay no but like the interview was so
weird it was like and by the way busy I
saw her and watch up inside and I was
really like surprised at how cute she
was like she were the cutest a fan she
has a bangin body and she changed three
times into three ugly big moose put on
she's like I was really like she had
braids in and watch I was like I was
like damn she looks so cute
I can't wait to see what kind of looks
she's pulling with that a budget night
gowns three times in a row yeah well
then I was watching it and I and I said
and I was said to tack I was like we can
never get a TV show could because they
ruin everything like and there's no way
that we would come to TV and like people
would like us but then I was thinking
you know this has been a 24 hour thought
process I was like we made this show to
be like our own TV show because like the
network's don't know be the TV show you
wish to see in the world so like our
show is made for TV so like all you do
is they'll be in paste all you have to
do is just take this feed on the wire
and just put it on team and plug it into
Bravo right so that nothing has to
change but when you try and put a
digital person and then
chanting TV structure around it that's
where everything gets lost in the
shuffle and I don't and I do think she's
funny and cute and like she has and like
she's very in tune to the culture she's
here for it shook Canton Chan
when she was like a countable chair she
were I can't okay when she was like and
also I just didn't I didn't agree with
her like he's a tennis player he does
have a right to say something just
because he's not a woman doesn't mean he
doesn't get to have an opinion with the
Roger Federer thing he said that Serena
Williams overreacted when the umpire was
like so mean
took her point away and umpire was wrong
and Serena Williams was justified in
yelling at him at her actually but like
Roger Federer is like you can't yell at
a time higher and you know what that's a
valid statement for our fellow tennis
player to say the Millenial said the
person we have no idea who they are no I
was saying the same thing cuz then I
went I was like Busy Philipps is an
actress and she kept referring to
herself as an actress like when she was
talking to Julia Roberts all these
acting friends and I don't I've seen her
and stuff so I wondered and I feel
pretty when is she from original Freaks
and Geeks Dawson's Creek oh yeah and you
know what I'm gonna I'm gonna [ __ ] ever
say it
I don't watch I never started on screen
meet you I'm not into the Katie Holmes
of it all no and like James and her beak
I loved you in don't recipe yeah no I'm
not playing James but I think that that
role secured her as like a permanent
celebrity yeah and her husband is a
big-time director and I think he put her
in I feel pretty good and Michelle
Williams cuz they're best friends and
it's like I was having this conversation
when I was in LA I was with some
industry people and they were like
asking me about what I do and I like
went off I'm just like the whole network
not understanding digital thing and I'm
like here's the thing Busy Philipps
is in Hollywood like she's friends with
Michelle Williams her husband is a
big-time director she just started a
movie with Amy Schumer like the reason
of the reason why we were interested in
giving you a show is because like you
have access and if you're gonna give a
show and like be like a family and you
have to let us into that access and she
like once it's like it's hard because
once you become famous for being a fan
you don't want to be a fan anymore do
you know what I mean it's like the way
that we talk about reality stars but
then also like a text with them it's
like it gets murky you know yeah but
it's like if you're given a show on E we
want it we want to hear about Michelle
Williams like how was she after Heath
Ledger like you have to give that to us
and if you're not really to give us that
access as a famous person who's also a
fan then you're not deserving of the
platform that that is the conclusion I
came to last night I agree now let's
talk about I'm you know I feel like it
will get better because like all things
like they will learn from everything but
it's
it's been rough however the lady and I
was feeling sad because they did want to
come on here and bash right female
programming female programming based off
of digital like how like are our cousins
our brothers and sisters
but then I was reinvigorated with a new
life from lady gang me too okay and I
didn't know I thought it was a reality
show about the three girls and I was
like a little script I don't know what
the format was gonna be and it seems
like there's something hanging out -
yeah but it was really like they record
a podcast I don't know if they put up
the podcast I think they do their
podcast separate and then they do lady
in TV podcast and other miscellaneous
items okay so I knew nothing about I've
never like I obviously know that they're
similar to us but I didn't know anything
about the girls I obviously know Becca
Tobin cuz I loved her and I was just so
wonderfully surprised in the most
positive way like first of all they're
so funny like and they really have to
find roles like Becca's like the crazy
out outgoing like funny grilled one I'm
the one on the left
Keltie like keeps [ __ ] going but it's
still like not annoying like she's fun
she's like the mom but she's a cool
she's not a regular mom she's a cool the
kids at least amount of Instagram
followers but she's not at least
interesting you know like yeah she keeps
things going in a funny organic way yes
then the girl in the middle is one like
I haven't decided how I feel about her
yet jack
jacqueline jack i always has jack
vernacular I guess it's Jack Banach do
you know who she is just to make all
those like cool t-shirts those thick
bracelets you definitely remembered like
those thick rubber blades bracelets at
LIVESTRONG know you doubt if I showed
you one you would know it I like I
bought one once and all these like cool
graphic teacher she's like a cool girl
so I think she's like the free spirit of
the body she you know is the others who
are married and like she's a single one
yeah and the only thing that I didn't
love about her was like her the role
that they put her in is like this free
spirit
I don't think comes naturally to her and
she was like playing a role where it's
like the other girls are very naturally
like momager vibe and crazy like
outgoing vibe that like they don't have
to play a role they're just being
themselves whereas like she's been put
in this box and she's like working at it
do you know any me and I felt the
opposite I felt like she like just
knowing who she is from like Instagram
in like the past 10 years like I feel
like she says she's so alternative
free-spirited like the fact that she has
a show on e now it goes against
everything that she once stood for cuz I
feel like she's the kind of girl who
could have been on the hills
she wanted to and so it's like like it's
just weird but it's an interesting take
yeah so back at Tobin I know the
breakouts starvation she was like
talking about how she would do her sex
tape from the side so she could get a
good side profile when she was talking
about how sex for breakfast is the
grossest thing she's ever gonna I was
like thank you you know for everyone who
that can't say it the show is very sex
heavy like yeah or so that I thought
because it's on late and I'm talking
about like their season one budget and
no so the breaking of the fourth wall
was my absolute favorite um I think the
show is so well done like the way they
break between like the table the side
interview and then like those weird
clips it like I could do without like
her going on the date except the date
was really funny and the guy was really
cute yes she was cute and but she was
she was really she was like the crazier
got the more he was into me and which is
always not it was always a red flag and
which was true because every time she
said something less like don't you dare
say that he was like yeah no overall I
think they're speak they're doing a
great job representing podcast I think
they will have a second season I think
that it was really good I don't like to
listen to other podcasts but I think if
I did I would want to listen to theirs
yeah
except like I'm a little annoyed by the
girl in the middle I haven't decided yet
how I feel about her give her time and
and I I can do with my skate it's like
let the ladies speak I so that's what I
was saying it's like he goes for this
like structure structure structure and
the lady game girls are the exact girls
who don't need it
busy needs that like let's play happy
endings Oh aha let you hudley like
whatever like they like sheen the busy
show needs that stupid like kitschy [ __ ]
to make it like five minutes here
commercial break five minutes two
minutes guests like they need that
structure whereas the lady game if they
just sad for 30 minutes I could listen
to them and also like busy what about a
co-host like a friend or sister that's
by the way that's what it is pressure
for one person it's clearly never hosted
before that they're never helmed their
own check Jackie that is it she needs a
co-host or not even a co-host like how
Jimmy Fallon has like the guy yeah
someone should we banter with ya not
chewy
no but LC handler had chewy oh yeah yeah
go oh yeah yeah yeah she needs something
well I guess that's when she has her
writers oh my god they don't talk a one
writer who puts her grandma and all like
every week every episode they do an
Instagram call send us a picture of you
doing this and one writer makes her
grandma do every single picture thing
and puts it in and this is whatever in
Tallahassee to [ __ ] it was
like the Julia Roberts fake boomerang
thing what they call it the fobian like
not in tune it's a boomerang that's
where they lost me okay yeah so ways for
those who didn't watch those shows
really sorry for the power yeah and when
you really knit miss much but I would
really recommend late again I thoroughly
enjoyed it and we do still have a lot of
people here so thank you for for
sticking with us for sticking with us
and we do have really good stories today
the world turn this weekend yeah and so
did we actually and actually I hosted my
first like evening at my house and
evening miss girls in the job I hosted
an evening with girl with no job I
haven't let people at my house yet
because I just haven't had a couch and I
really am the type of person where it's
like I don't want to formally like um
entertain until I'm done furnishing but
it's taking so goddamn long like I had
to move on with my life and everyone
family came over yesterday for the day
we just had like such a great time you
were such a show fat like oh man we were
so fat we were so funny I was as I was
feeling asleep last night it was like
laughing at all of them Jackie drunk on
McFlurry is like you were acting
literally like you smoked weed like you
really couldn't stop laughing your face
was bright red and like no one else was
laughing everyone was I think ya know
but like it was so so funny like what
like what were we even laughing about I
mean we were laughing about Co because
Co I don't know if you guys know this he
is actually just received his doctorate
and he's now a doctor yeah dr. Theo
Fitch Emin for those of you watch 30
rock you'll know that it's just an
acclaimed I claimed heritage to be a
part of the the Chapman family the
Chapman family basically I feel like
we're I don't know me like we're steno
balling this joke okay so this is what
happened I was looking see his face and
I was like beautiful face man like -
face of a man it's so beautiful space
man the way we talk to him is like out
of control like don't be naughty boy
nice man a wonderful treasure new boy
and so I said the words facing man and
Claudia was like thanks man beautiful
man
and I was like dr. face man and you go
doctor for chairman like doctors but
jamming from 30 counter space man and
then cut and then literally an hour
later after making the jokes 700 times
we've realized that dr. Spach Emmons
first name is Leo for Chapman and we
were like reopen Shemin I know Leo
speech Evan you know the challenge and
now we have a doctor in the family right
and we've always wanted one wait
someone's write prescriptions
hey dr. King take a look at this right
and like it was funny until we also
realized the Leo
the of it all I'm like then it was just
the greatest joke we ever made and also
we were talking about how if we all get
dogs like Omni mine Clio Margot will
name her CEO and we said Olivia Lee ran
out of yoyo you'll name yours Geo and we
just said it like she should just agree
and she was like well gee oh yeah and
then she came up with Rio which is so
cute so now we all have to get dogs but
we were just dying we were being so
banana actually I'm like embarrassed to
say because I was entertaining last
night then it became one of those homes
that like makes people take those shoes
off in the front I mean it's a new home
so I don't know if it'll last but like
at least to start I vacuumed so
frequently like I just figured I would
make my life a little bit easier and
everyone was laying on the couch it
wasn't like fun it was it was a good
pre-emptive move I was upset to take off
my new MJ me shoes because I've been
living in them you really have I have
them too but like I wear them in any
time I'm wearing a sneaker now I guess
all my other sneakers are dirty and
these are actually made of like real
Italian leather and they can they can
handle my lifestyle right and I love
them so much and every time I wear them
like Zach complements me and he's a real
sneaker head he is so it's a big
compliment I'm like MJ me like go - MJ
me calm and use Koto's for $50 off your
first order
yeah just major it's like I wear
sneakers all the time it's like annoying
to spend money on sneakers that [ __ ]
just like they have a three month shelf
life so it's like I'm happy to spend a
little bit more in a pair of shoes the
ones that I bought from em Jimmy were
sneakers but it's like I can wear them
out and like they can still be alive the
next day do you know what I mean yes and
now I need another pair from him Jaime
because um I'm changed your tape I
thought you could just wear shoes like
white sneakers from Target and it would
accomplish it would have the same effect
no like do you know how many pairs of
sneakers saying you have to buy like
every time you wear them you need a new
pair right like are made of the good
stuff you know it's like it's like the
same it's the same manufacturing in the
same leather and the same materials as
like Gucci yeah but it's not $700 no
which I can I can do that right okay so
obviously we have affordable for what it
is it's affordable and it's even more
affordable because you know homegirls
because you're so go see for yourself
how amazing these shoes are at MGM e.com
slash toasts for $50 off your first pair
that's letter M G EMI dot-com / toast
for $50 off your first pair MJ me calm /
toast
MJ me a teller and luxury made the old
way sold the new way and I know that a
bunch of toasts
Scott M gemenese the last time we spoke
about them Rene got and they loved them
so like we only really promote premium
brands no and I'm gonna use our own code
to get a new pair yeah no I'm gonna get
I want to get loafers well oh you wanted
the over suit were these tomorrow oh my
god I know I'm freaking out that I'm not
that I'm not freaking out enough and I
was thinking this morning I was I was
doing my makeup I was like maybe I
should have like done something like no
with like a big blowout but that's just
not who I am anymore and all I really
want for my birthday is pasta and Seanie
vibes no so I'm eating so good today and
tomorrow because tomorrow night I'm
[ __ ] feasting I'm starving today well
no not starving I'm eating healthy and
oh no SoulCycle TRL musicals Jaggi that
brings me to a point I wanted to make
because you know a couple of weeks ago
we had somewhat controversial discussion
on the show about it's calling someone
skinny the same it's calling someone
fast yeah obviously it's not but the
world is trying to make us think that it
is but I refused to give it I've given
it to all of the world's demands I'm not
getting into this one now I wanted to
ask you a question because there was a
post in the toasters that got reported
like a bunch of times and I didn't know
whether or not to delete it because I
wanted to I wanted to figure out what
how I felt on it because someone posted
a picture of a girl from The Bachelor
who was like really skinny and was like
it looks like I saw the post yeah it was
like it looks like this girl has gained
like a little bit of like healthy weight
and she was singing in a very positive
way she wasn't calling her like that by
any and she was like this girl is like
really skinny and it looks like she's
put on like three or four pounds like
just to really help like you know
health-wise and it got reported so many
times I guess if that was offensive so I
deleted it I did you yes I was going
back and forth like the original but
there was nothing wrong with the
original pose but the comment it's the
one but it's just like it opens up a can
of worms and not everyone is gonna be so
respectful and I just don't want to be a
group where we're talking about that
people would wait and if they gained
three or four pounds because then like
they'll be talking about us every day
that's in a Manning point so I was it
was just Pandora's Box is closed on this
but so let's not talk about people's
weight when they're being brave and
posting a bikini picture Jackie that's
why you're so wise like seriously this
business would be a failure without you
like I just do reckless things and I
think I'm so right in the moment then
you explain it to me and I'm like oh
that's a good point yes but you do also
ask me a lot of the time yeah of course
you know we're not like super Isis
because you do ask for a lot of people's
opinions before you make no I will write
in our chat like 17 times before I make
any decision and I just like I'm not
confident enough in my decisions a lot
of the time because they make so many
about
no and Justin it's hard to like see
every aspect of a problem but just like
we were saying on the patreon how like I
might actually be a good therapist
yeah when I was talking about how you
keep talking [ __ ] about your old
apartment because you want to make
yourself feel better about like leaving
it even though it's a wonderfully
perfectly wasn't [ __ ] all I hate it but
what are your thoughts just outside of
the actual post it made me think it's
like okay so if you told a bigger person
that they lost weight that's a
compliment so on the opposite if you had
told a smaller person that they gained
weight is that the same to me like I'm
biased because I only think in my own
like from my own person gray or
somewhere like you gaining weight is
negative for me and losing weight as a
positive because that's just my body
type I've never the world we live it
I've never been like small enough to
have to gain weight so for me it's not
the same but maybe for someone who has
been called too skinny one too many
times it is a compliment
right I just don't know because like I
said I can never put myself in that
position I'll never ever ever ever know
what it feels like to have someone beat
like eat a cheeseburger you know yeah
okay bring me one yeah where no yeah I
don't get I don't get that oh my god we
were so excited last night we got for
dinner wasn't our fault
no it wasn't we tried to get one
delivery of Italian feast everyone was
coming over at 4:30 for the game at 3
o'clock I hadn't eaten all day I was
waiting but feast II vibes at 3 o'clock
I ordered a huge like literally $300
meal from Carmine's like it all comes
family-style in this big tins like I
wanted like a real Italian feast cuz
I've recently decided that I'm gonna be
Italian and just like eat a lot on
Sundays melissa gorga like made me want
to do it so I think it makes you eat
better during them because you know you
have this thing waiting for you right so
at 3 o'clock I knew it was gonna be a
long delivery it's like it's a fancy
place and they have an 80 minute weight
on seamless so I'm like okay
three o'clock everyone will get here by
like 5 o'clock it'll definitely be here
literally by 5:30 to an athlete order
still hadn't come and it hadn't even
left the restaurant I was like so mad so
I cancelled it and then we just like we
were so hungry and angry which is a bad
combo you're hangry that we [ __ ] went
while so like Claudia order and
McDonald's for herself I ordered like
some kosher poppers for the group then I
realize Katya didn't order enough she
didn't she only ordered McDonald's fries
for herself so then I also ordered a
couple orders of McDonald's fries then
then ordered pizzas for everyone that
was the only thing we could have done
with that because we had already screwed
all the food and then the pizza came
like 30 minutes
we were like are you kidding me I would
say Bernadette its 1106 on eleven five
and it's just like at this time tomorrow
it'll be my birthday on my birthday you
know exciting also what's exciting is
for my birthday what we're giving to the
toasters yeah we need to get them
prepared yeah we also need to get
ourselves free right so we have to get
for you guys tomorrow yeah we will
announce tomorrow on the show but have
your hearts minds wallets prepared so
just know then your wife I just know
that this is the season of giving and
we're crazy generous so just know that
in the next two months there's a lot of
coming your way and also it's it's it's
a given take because I feel like we are
now as a chose community we're doing
something positive we're raising money
for Gift of Life
we have our toast cycle this week on
Thursday which we've already raised
$2,500 for just for the tickets but if
you can't come please you can still
donate I'll put the link in on our
Facebook page and everywhere just like
you can still donate to gift of life
having been to the Gift of Life gala
just like seeing the good work they do I
wanted to give them literally all my
money like I was just dying from like
the positivity so we give and we receive
so have your hearts wha wallets and
mines open tomorrow for some person
premium content for some premium stuff
and I mean this is just the next like
these next few weeks are still premium
because next week we're going to CMA for
we're going to Nashville for CMA Awards
and I just like I need to tell everyone
like what we're doing but we just wait
for the paperwork you say you can't have
a second the paperwork is filed for our
records we are just gonna like shout it
from the rooftops I'm so excited yeah
you're gonna be proud of your girls
you're gonna be proud of us yeah we
still need to find the perfect thing to
wear okay without further ado because oh
wait and speaking of the perfect thing
to wear I got something to wear that
clock is not changed I was like how is
it already noon oh that is hilarious
yeah yeah wait just one more thing what
did you just say that sent me off Oh
what to wear for I forgot to tell you
this so when we the day we sat here and
you were like I want to wear a tuxedo to
the CMA Awards among oh I want to wear a
jumpsuit I went to Bloomingdale's and I
do my personal shopping with Lisa who I
adore someone sent me like a stylist
like pic looks for me via email and sent
me like all these looks and I mean did I
say this on the show already no you said
it to me in the big work Cuba expensive
so expensive so I need a stylist who can
pull stuff that bar is free and I can
give back to you ready make an amend
addendum to
request so I got the two things to fold
I got this jumpsuit mint yeah amendment
I got this jumpsuit that I loved and I
showed you and you approved have to get
them Hampton stuff but it's a one-armed
jumpsuit so I always cover my arms and
it's like I've definitely like lost a
good amount of weight and I'm moving in
a direction where I would like to show
my arms eventually and probably a
one-armed thing is a great way to start
like 50% but I'm just having like
terrible anxiety about it I have to see
on you I will give you honest feedback
about your arm and there is a way that
you could wear the one jumpsuit the
whole time and if I cooperate and stay
on my side like we'll never even know I
was gonna say you're gonna have to if
you would let me wear this like you're
gonna have to do whatever Simon what so
the arm is you have your right arm
covered it's a mirror picture so I got
an idea I think I have my left arm
covered okay so I would be like this I'm
sure actually but the reason I want to
tell you is that she also had picked a
tuxedo for me and I tried it on it was
like very Diane Keaton and I bought the
pants I didn't buy the whole look
because I don't think I could rock a
jump a tuxedo yet and I didn't love the
jacket but like I was really being
touched by a Kourtney Kardashian I
didn't like the jacket my god no
yeah it was the wrong jacket but there
you look like Mason yeah totally but
like you should definitely invest in the
Texas of time okay figuring that out
okay I will okay without further ado Oh
40 minutes later here are the fast eye
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast okay first story in the
continuing saga of Ariana and Pete and
things are really getting crazy no it's
like things have gone crazy yeah they
have we're out of new levels Ariana
Grande and Pete Davidson named drop each
other in new song and on SNL star cross
exes Ariana and Pete made affectionate
public amends Saturday night
first the singer dropped a new single
thank you next mentioning her former
fiance in the line quote even almost got
married and for Pete I'm so thankful
then the comic turned serious during
Saturday Night Live's Weekend Update
segment making a big statement about her
I happened to be watch SNL live on
Saturday night because you know that's
what you do when you're a grandma and
you stay in and Pete was on Weekend
Update like being funny doing his thing
and then he was like he turned to the
camera he's like and for everyone who
wants to know about the break-up like
Ariana's a great girl and I was
literally grabbing Zach I was like oh my
god that's why I was so shocked but I
guess what this is what
and so he made that video that promo
proposing to Maggie Rogers who by the
way blew my mind on SNL like that rarely
happens where I'm so pleasantly
surprised and I hear from an artist
whose music I would like but I've never
heard before usually Spotify serves them
to me I guess I've been listening to so
much wickaninnish oh man I missed her
yeah that can happen she was incredible
her voice her songs were so good she
just like had like Florence Welch vibe
to her and I highly recommend her so I
understand my Pete proposed to her and
she said no and so then Arianna put out
her song right before SNL aired she must
have known that people's about to make a
statement on SNL addressing the rumors
and so she put her song out first and
her song is amazing I'm so sweet unlike
the rest of her album and when she calls
him Malcolm like I just want to die I
just when she started out this song like
I saw that snitch was like posting that
Ariana had a new song so I was like okay
and I thought I'd start listening to it
I'm like did she say Sean like Big Sean
right and then she talks about Ricky
and then now come and pee and I was like
dead for scenes no it's just so funny
cuz like all last week there was like
built-up tension like with the tweet and
then the promo and you think that like
Saturday night she's releasing his song
he's being his day but it's gonna be
like combative and they're both just
like respectful and lovely and they're
moving on with their lives
yes and it was it is 11:11 make-a-wish
good she better be a bad [ __ ] baggage
baggage baggage baggage baggage bag I
might just be the beauty bag I was just
seeing the weather man for myself on my
birthday tomorrow depending on what my
gifts are I was in say like what does
that get superheroes right no I know so
that's why I always did you tell me when
I meet you back I don't know buddy I
don't know I told my one in something
else ever and he thought he's getting me
what I wanted what are the earrings okay
because I got my ears part right um and
he doesn't want to show so I don't even
think he knows that I want to go too bad
so hard having non-supportive husband so
you don't watch our show but I'm so glad
they don't want to my god every day
would come when you said this you know
Tim Tebow juggy like literally like once
in a while better watch a show and be
like so Derek Hough yeah I'm like just
just stay we're not watching here's the
thing that are gonna meet like on the
one hand it's like they're both being
thirsty and milking this around the
other hand it's like I need public
breakup
content because of how much public
relationship content so miss Eyre
you can't just pretend like it never
happened yeah no I know brace being
respectful and she's putting out better
music than her last
oh so she doesn't you album ready to go
yes she said that she had it and she
wanted to release it before the end of
the year but that's insane
the thieves don't put out a new album
for two years and then you put out two
albums in five months and also like I'm
gonna say this and I know it's
controversial maybe I haven't given
enough of a listen
but sweeteners is not good Ariana's
songs are not good and when we went to
the list watch all of her live videos we
were just watching YouTube videos on
Friday night and we were like let's we
watch The Wizard and I Ariana so we
wanted to watch more more I've [ __ ] and
all of her songs recently since my
everything are not good
so it's not controversial I think the
songs are good and everything it's like
no but like breaths it's like a Camila
Kibeho release that album like it would
be fine and we just expect so much from
Ariana she is the vocalist of our
generation and it's not reflected that
exact opposite we expect nothing for her
from her because her voice is so good
and she will be an icon forever because
of that if Camila Cabello put him out
add an album like this she would fall
off the charts no I disagree because I
don't dislike the album I just don't
think it does anything for Ariana for a
million reasons like the songs are fine
like this sleep excuse me because don't
like it's good it's fine it's cute and
if someone with like a soft not even
coming like a baby but she is a great
boy someone with like a soft breathy
voice like I don't know it just it's not
the right album for her who like is a
loves Broadway and like loves show tunes
and can sing any song and [ __ ]
performed at Aretha Franklin's funeral
like you don't perform at Aretha
Franklin's funeral and then release
breathing do you mean yeah yeah cuz
she's an icon like yeah and this is that
was not an icon it's not reflective I
mean I need a much more of my everything
into you album must dangerous woman yes
interest woman you ever seen the video
blocking my video of her wearing the map
the the bunny ears and she's just
walking around singing dangerous woman
it must be nice she's literally so
beautiful so perfect yeah but she has
demons she has demons yeah it's you know
what it's like she's the perfect example
of like just from what you see like
she's the perfect life like she is so
beautiful she's like has such a
supportive family like she's a million
friend she says top of her started like
diamond threats ruined through the most
haunted person gets every opportunity
and like she struggles and like she
definitely has demons and it's like
we're all equal nobody is exempt no and
it's like you can have so much and then
what's that law where it's like grants
balance you know that the like that the
higher you go the further you fall so
something like that you know what I mean
I don't know some of them it's just like
most people are like here and here but
she's like here her highs are high and
her those are that were that we will
ever know yeah no that's that's very
true but I do think she's like a good
role model like I think she has a lot of
young followers and as much as she's
like she's like you're like a celebrity
like she's loving the fame like I think
she takes that responsibility like
seriously and I think she is a good role
model for her young followers I think
she's a good girl my don't anything
she's a realistic role model like she
sings out like sex and stuff I think God
is what like you know her songs have
innuendos so she's not pretending like
she's a Jonas Brother purity right but
she's also like not you know Miley Cyrus
bangers Chucky the rule is inertia of
Murphy's Law yeah what goes up whatever
that's gravity Murphy's Law is anything
I can't go wrong we'll right no that's
Jackie's law no there's one with the
apple doesn't fall far from the tree
Newton fig Isaac Isaac I can't we need
to get our new general AWS together yeah
our laws in order okay
next story really so crazy piggybacking
off of our segment on Friday but the
bachelorettes Kaitlyn Bristowe and Sean
Booth split quote we're committed to
remaining friends on Friday on Friday
they released this statement to people I
wouldn't close after three incredible
years we have decided to go our separate
ways this difficult decision comes after
thoughtful respectful consideration even
though we are parting us a couple we're
very much committed to remaining friends
and we will continue to support each
other they right so to the nature of how
we met our relationship has always been
public and we have enjoyed sharing it
with all of you but we ask that you
respect our decision and privacy at this
difficult time
yeah that's not I don't think there's a
reflection of what actually happened or
that's gonna tell us anything that's
like a professional publicist who just
like had to put it out there I'm so
upset and I'm so devastated for so many
reasons like just having been in their
presence like they really were just like
in love and you can like you could feel
it and they were like a realistic couple
they didn't pretend like every picture
was photoshopped and a million things
and it's like they were real like like
they were just open and honest about a
lot of stuff and like I'm really
that they didn't work out like I'm so
I'm sad for a million reasons but more
like for myself you know yeah I'm sad I
just had like a total tangent I was
gonna just go on a tangent about
something completely unrelated but I'm
gonna try and remember and I think I can
about the movie that we need to talk
about yeah I know I've been thinking
about attributes like write us down yeah
I'm [ __ ] wall I'm really sad I really
am surprised and I'm surprised that it
came like so quickly after that rumor
that had start and that's what I member
when I said II definitely know something
that they can't say because nothing
public has come out I meant I think more
that like everyone was speculating it
but they were speculating it in like
private Facebook groups and on Twitter
there was like it was just people
speculating and like they didn't need to
address it if it's just like toasters
writing threads about it but once a real
news publication picked it up it like it
needs elicits a response yes but also
with Bachelor breakups that usually
break up a little bit before the
statement comes out because it gets a
while it takes a while to get to that
point so they have been broken it yeah
for a while I think I don't know what a
while isn't even if it's just a week she
gets to keep the ring right yes it is
still more than two years but she did
you have to give it but she had given it
back to him because they were gonna do
new pre-proposal did you think he's
gonna give it back to her I think that
he should anything would what would he
want with it well I've spoken to Caitlin
and I just like what's letting her know
that like I'm here for her and I think
she's like she just said like she's just
sad like it's and I'm sad like I'm sad
I'm sad for me like I enjoyed the
content
I enjoyed the snapback beam snapchat
rickanddonna like I just the content was
there you know what something like this
makes me think because I really feel
like they they're they were so good for
each other and when they first were
together like without all the outside
forces maybe they could have made it
work and it's sometimes like really love
is not enough you know because I feel
like they what they had was love and
everything else like work in different
careers in celebrity and taking down and
different paths and starting your own
business now being on The Bachelor it's
like it takes you away from the love and
like sometimes really love is not enough
to keep two people together that is so
sad ya know and I think that's just a
true statement overall but why not I
don't know right like a really you do
have to work hard at accept like I feel
like my marriage is very easy
knock on wood knock on wood saying you
always working out relationship I really
it's one thing I don't have to work out
yeah well you work out a lot of other
stuff you can't have it all in this
column you have something
this column you don't like some people
read a podcast and it just is a great
success automatically and but their
relationship is trash drop with his
front with peril yes you know what I
mean life is a deck of cards ya know a
hand of cards the deck of cards but you
get dealt a hand of cards and you might
get a great relationship but you have to
work harder at your career but you also
do have a great career so yeah just keep
knocking on wood oh my god the million
dollar question is what about Doodle
Tucker I the dog is Shawn's right and he
had him way before the bachelor but on
Friday when before this news dropped
Kaitlyn had a story where she was
wearing a face mask and watching
something about a dog and started crying
about how much she loves Tucker doodle
oh and she's not going down without a
fight
well here's the thing is she gonna stay
in Nashville is he did she she she is
definitely gonna stay in Nashville and
because she's still recording music and
she her life is in Nashville like her
full life is there his gym is there they
are both 100% staying in Nashville but
they have a house together I'm assuming
that Kaitlyn
lookey that will keep the house also
because I think for a while she was like
the earner in the relationship so I'm
pretty sure like her roots are in the
house financially but this is all just I
don't know anything I'm just speculating
I think Tucker will go back with Shawn
but I think I don't know it's like
that's like the saddest part like I saw
this meme it was like Ariana now takes
care of max dog and it's like Mac just
like I mean Ariana like picked up the
dog and let the dog we'll never know
who'll never see Mac again you know it's
so sad so sad and I think Caitlyn will
say Nashville she also posted that she
wrote a song yeah her dad was there so
like she's now becoming an artist she
has we heard one of her songs then she
came yeah while we went to her show or
was it we heard that her lines
oh no we weren't had a nice knowing well
we heard it at college we heard in a
while ago yeah I know what was in her
mind I think it was yours because I
don't think it was hers because he's not
a thing she way yeah so at her live show
at Caroline's in the greenroom she
played us one of her songs and it was so
good like it was real like that like I
wasn't expecting like a real song and it
was highly produced and really good it
was really good so I look forward to
seeing what she does next
who she dates and I know it's too early
to talk that's too early but like she's
like she's a podcaster and she's like a
legit celebrity show so it's just
interesting like who you date can really
like rise your star and if you like use
that to your advantage
I and I think I could see here what's
that country star Jackie if we were
single like okay and we were like out on
the town ya know that he could like date
people like our own level to like rise
our star like other like influencers are
like low level select who would it be
like who would you date well that's why
I was saying to snitch last night cuz
she's the only single one left and
that's why we need to get her seen with
Shawn Mendes right so everyone's like
you know Shawn Mendes and he needs like
another fake girlfriend I'll just take
you on a date with the snitch and then
we get Shawn Mendes his date exclusive
interview like she really needs to start
doing that for us yeah she can she can't
because she's like so pretty and busty
like boys love her but who would you be
spotted out with I think like I would
really try and like make the world think
I was dating Peter Krause that's a good
one
because people are so interested in his
love life Yeah right cuz the bachelor
thing it's like they're famous enough
that like you'll get written up in
tabloids like made me be spoken about on
like Access Hollywood or something but
it's not like you can't leave the house
that paparazzi you know right or maybe
like someone from like a Bravo everyone
from Anna pump is taken yeah like a New
York Bravo show you even like Mario
singer Mario singers newest mistress I
heard Mario and Ramona are back together
did you Mario will never have a
girlfriend he will only ever have a
mistress of course he's eternally
married to Ramona that day I heard that
they're back together
I hope so meet you I'm here saying I did
not hear for single Ramona she's a
butcher she's a vulture and like I feel
like she she lived her single life and
like now she's even like more fun and
her and Mario could have like a put like
a their golden years together of being
like fun and enjoying life cuz she like
she just needed this renewal of energy
renew when a rejuvenation
but notice how that true renewal true
narrow hi Ramona Singer that is hard to
say that's like the world juror
larger urban firm her have we only done
one story but it we do okay next story
but they're all celebs so it's like
we're just freezing through him Demi
Lovato is spotted out of rehab and in LA
three months after hospitalization I saw
she looks so good the 26 year old pop
star recently completed three months of
treatment at a rehab center following an
apparent over two
in July Wow it's at 3 months yeah at her
la home and almost two weeks hospital
stay the singer who has battle substance
abuse for years has spent time in rehab
before went out for sushi in Beverly
Hills on Saturday night with designer
Henry Alexander levy the two were
photographed in a car two outside the
Matsuhisa restaurant Matsuhisa so I feel
like Demi is the type of celebrity who
like doesn't go to treatment like like
she celebrities are always like in and
out of like 30 day facilities that it's
like so fake and they do it for
publicity like I feel like when she goes
she takes recovery really [ __ ]
treatment lightly right so I feel like
she's like most of them go for it I mean
LuAnn went for two weeks like they all
go for like a month
she went for three months like that is a
good amount of time I feel like if she's
ready to come I trust her her instincts
and I like like that she takes her
recovery like not as a joke and not as
like a PR stunt I agree and I don't know
a lot about recovery but three months
seems like a good amount of time to like
recover and I'm sure now that she's out
of recovery like she's still in some
sort of program like I remember in what
was her documentary called Oh simple
tell me you love me it was one of her
songs oh yeah it was like I'm confident
and now you have to find it out oh it's
annoying me so much I'm waiting for the
comments um no I think I could do a
quick Kira
Demi lavato documentary simply
complicated yeah oh really
that was that doesn't sound familiar to
me yeah that wasn't the answer I was
hoping for um but then when she did
leave treatment like she was then in a
house where with other sober people and
she didn't go back to her life
immediately so it was like a halfway
it's a halfway house is four people in
prison but it's the same concept where
it's like you're not fully out of the
program right so so we're living sober
living yeah that was so crazy that
documentary was so good for so many
reasons because I learned so much but
what I was really shocked by but she was
like when I was literally making 25
million dollars a year doing X Factor on
TV three times a week alive I was living
in a sober living on a bunk bed like
that was so crazy and that's how you
know like she's serious right so I think
she's probably in a situation like that
right now trying to get back to normal
life whatever she needs I'm here for her
if it means not talking about her
anymore like whatever whatever we can do
to help so just put out like a statement
of what we
new to help and support you but I feel
like everyone has been so supportive and
you know she has what she needs and
she's like literally the best fans yeah
I love her like I am a true Tammy stand
oh and we were watching on Friday night
we were just like going through crazy
YouTube videos like of people singing
cuz like that's my actual favorite
activity to do and it's also the point
favorite activity to do and we watched
all the celebrities who sang the
national anthem at various like sporting
events of Super Bowl and we watched
Emmys and it's like I always forget like
she's also a true vocalist yeah and
she's music like it sucks but like her
voice I think musics great and I think
her voice is great her music she always
has at least one amazing song on every
hour some albums are better than last
not this album but the album before it
with um like Lion Heart or wherever I
don't know was really great it's like
the songs that they choose to make
famous from our albums are the worst one
like tell me it sorry not sorry like I
can't but there were a few songs on her
album that were like wonderful ballads
but like nobody cares about those songs
I'm like that's what's upsetting yeah I
agree
okay next story because Margaret Roses
is here and I just can't wait another
minute and this is a quick one Kenya
Moore and husband Mark daily welcomed a
baby girl good honestly like this is
truly all she's ever wanted and you know
how like having a baby like changes
people like mm-hmm forever like she's
the type of person who like could use a
little change and I'm looking forward to
her being like a more better but she's
off the show right that's like
frustrating because now she like has the
life that she wanted to have on the show
and the life that she pretended to have
for so long oh and it's like she has a
husband and has a baby so what part was
she thinking the part like that her
husband won't be on the show no she was
faking like before her last season like
she was faking forever about these like
boyfriend right and his relationship at
the time to be kicked off not right when
no that's the best slide but like her
life is actually like I don't know what
should I get off I think so that's what
I heard I don't I can't even like put
remember the things that I've heard no
but I have recorded real houses of
Atlanta last night I didn't watch it yet
and I've decided like I'm going to be a
good like Atlanta fan I always watch
Atlanta like halfway through the season
and like catch up and then like watch
the reunion I'm very like disorganized
about it but I think it's a franchise
that most people sleep on now and it's
opposite everyone's woke on it it's
really us yeah I just can't get hurt
I've missed
miss to any seasons maybe like when I
was in college or something and it
there's so much history there's with so
much diversity like you can miss the
[ __ ] Alexis Bellino seasons and
you'll be ok right
you can't miss any Atlanta so I always
just because they have roots like they
run deep right and the fights run deep
and like you can't make informed
decisions if you don't know the past
it's so true because when I like
randomly popped in like a couple seasons
ago I was very on phaedra side and like
I still kind of like a love failure and
I do you think like what she did was
wrong but like people have done worse on
the housewives and like for them to all
like take the making cancer right like
people have like and then they all took
like this moral high ground on Pedro
like I didn't like that and I loved her
like before that when she pulled her
baby out of her vagina and called in an
alien like I just love her but I don't I
didn't know enough about what had
happened before to like make an informed
decision but I've decided I'm going to
be a good Atlanta fan this season and
just like watch well that means that I
have to do all so first episode was last
night like we're we're okay and I
recorded if you want to come over we're
in a good spot and so I'm just not here
for candy like I just don't like her my
least favorite which is crazy because
she's like the most favorite of everyone
else she is you know she's the most
followed housewife on a tram which is
shocking no she's I can't I can't I
can't enchant it worked and I do like um
[ __ ] nevermind I guess I don't like
Porsche oh I love Porsche yeah like
she's stupid and like she makes bad
decisions and she's definitely not a
good or trustworthy friend but like
she's a great character on TV
agreed okay third and final story is
really sad a happened last night but
Texas newly Texas newlyweds reportedly
killed in a helicopter crash after
taking off from their wedding reception
a newlywed couple will Beiler and Bailey
Ackerman Tyler were killed in a
helicopter crash outside
Uvalde Texas after flying off after
their wedding on Saturday according to
reports quote is with deepest sadness
that we announced the tragic passing of
two seniors from Sam Houston State
University they were college students
they just got married they were flying
off into the sunset and their helicopter
crash we ask that you keep the buyer and
ackermann families in your thoughts and
prayers I will so sad so like all I saw
I got this news notification from daily
May last night so I looked at the story
and like all of the pictures that they
had were from their wedding like the bad
ones know the hour before that's so
[ __ ] sad like his ranch like they
were just like college sweethearts like
young and in love and like Tom
ranch terrible story a terrible horrible
story I feel like every couple years
there's a story like this like oh no
they're so sad like I've heard stories
like that where it's like it's literally
too sad to be true ready right I heard a
story like I'm literally never forget it
maybe five years ago this man died at
his own wedding reception he was dancing
holding a beer and he slipped and fell
on the glass of beer and the shot the
glass stabbed him like on his way down
hitting the floor like that is someone
who like God needs and it just like
needed to get him to heaven like right
in like didn't couldn't think of a
better plan it was so crazy and it's
like are you [ __ ] at his own wedding
that's crazy
I never heard that story speaking of
crazy stories and this is the thing I
had that we needed to talk about yes and
we don't have time to talk about today
but this is a good way to tell people
that they must watch this movie tonight
it is a toast movie of the night because
we will be discussing it at length
tomorrow and there's no time to wait the
movie three identical strangers if
you've seen it you know and if you
haven't you're about to be shook to your
[ __ ] core mmm its documentary
we'll leave it at that
I just have so many thoughts on it from
like a both medical and a sociological
standpoint that I just need to discuss
and I've been trying to discuss it for
so long and Jackie finally watched it
and now we need you guys to watch it I
don't know how you held in talking about
it for so long because like I am
bursting at the seams me [ __ ] too and
I'm also bursting at the seams because
we are running so behind because we were
supposed to bring out Margot Joseph's 15
minutes ago but we just couldn't stop
talking so give us a minute we will be
back in two seconds for the queen of
pigtails the powerhouse in pigtails
Margaret Cho sips if you have any
questions for her leave a comment on the
YouTube stream and we will get them to
her or on our Instagram we will see you
in a minute
you
we are back with the powerhouse in
pigtails and it's only right that we
respect her by putting on our own
pigtails give it up for the one the only
market Joseph's so great I love you and
thank you for wearing the pigtails of
course is bad and also answer look
really good no I'm feeling the look you
guys look amazing in pigtails real so
cute people don't realize pigtails are
fabulous on most people you really are
yeah and you have like the proper
equipment with your you have clear bands
yes I have the clear bands from my
piggies well cuz I'm blond
so I need yes oh yes I guess maybe two
contrasting yeah yours match your outfit
so it's good sure Oh cute and Meijer
match my hair yes perfect it's a nice
yeah so we are here to talk about Real
Housewives of New Jersey yeah new season
is coming this week Wednesday Wednesday
only on Bravo only on Bravo eight
o'clock and that's an early time Pam
nice all right we made the same mistake
with Melissa we sold to Melissa last
week and she just loves you I love
Melissa we're very close and people love
your friendship I know because you know
what we're both in business we're both
married to height challenged Little
Joe's oh you know so that's really and
we get along great and we both we start
the party we end the party we're just
fun girls and we don't take anything too
seriously which is the only way to live
I agree there is a general consensus
around you from the toasters and they
wanted us to today they wanted us to
thank you really for single-handedly
reviving the franchise that's so sweet
yes you toaster I think there was a lull
for a while and we didn't know it at the
time but like we needed pigtails and
that's really what brought us back to
life yeah and any gay man in a girl's
body and I think that's what it is
excited the little snark
and so you are now coming into your
third season correct second season know
all these seconds easily I've been here
forever there's been a season in between
the ciggy and now but they're having
this you saying is this again Jew did
you guys ever formally make up or yeah
no no I don't talk no I mean I went into
where I get my nails done she gets her
hair is done her hair's that's so Jersey
I'm dying
and I went into the salon and you know
she's getting her extensions you know
the one she wears down to her badge and
I walked in and she was like oh my god
Margaret's here I was like really girl
we not over this I was get my nails
she's not over I mean I'm over and I
could really give a crap but she is
there I need to be over it cause like
you're so show you guys sure that is yes
so crazy but that's not so it's
something to think about it's like you
live in a small town
even though jerseys being placed you
guys all live in like a similar locale
and it's yes you think about running
into your classmates it's true
absolutely you couldn't touch yes I
could easily run in turn you know when
she's in the room it's so loud so it's
fine yes so the murmur home is on
Wednesday so how is this season for you
your sophomore season I think to say
like what can we expect and how did you
go into it knowing that you were so
beloved in your first year like it's a
pressure no I think you know what I was
by genuine authentic self the first
season and I think I'm the exact same
person this season you know I make
people like my stag line says I make
them laugh and I make them cry just like
I did the first season I do it the
second season is it easier now filming
the second season like having the
friendships young is just you know that
is within that realm as opposed to
having to meet new people yeah so is of
course I had my friends I already had
Melissa to be honest it's easier to be
with Dolores cos Ziggy's not there so
Dolores and I she's a free agent now
yeah we do you guys always had enjoyed
relations you were having a good
relationship you know we were always
very cordial but I feel like this you
used to just abandon this thing you see
is building our relationship which is
very nice that's nice you see Jackie I
can get I'm friends with Jackie a nice
Jackie goes on Jackie you love a good we
everybody loves a good jacket is your
new housewife with two new housewives
they used to get to meet them why not
get along with much better I get along
with the blonde much better of course of
course
nope but Jennifer no Jennifer is you
know very interesting very interesting
margos is with the shade Jew a chi and
there's a lot going on in the whole Real
Housewives of New Jersey clan right now
two major stories and you were a maid of
honor or bridesmaid in Janelle's wedding
matron of honor made that is what matron
of honor and did a nice job yes and the
has since ended since and in 10 weeks 10
weeks and so when you film the reunion
yeah one we fell Maria you won't be able
to discuss it because party there as a
maid of honor did you see it coming you
know I think it's hard to get married in
the spotlight today's thing I mean you
know she didn't have a lot going for her
going into it when you when you watch it
when you see the episodes ooh it was
rough they didn't even sleep in the same
room you know the night of the wedding
I'm just given a little hint right there
so interesting so so yes you did see it
coming I saw I didn't think it was a
lifelong thing got it
so how was I don't know 10 weeks was the
time we decided housewife record 10
weeks yeah Harry Shum and LuAnn were
seven months Tom and Luanne yeah so
should be Tom and Lwin but you know
we're doing well you know 20 engagements
you know 10-week marriage engage 19
times engage 19 times 20 you know what
you two aren't on the best chums we're
not on the best terms we're not on the
best terms I think when you see it
unravel it's interesting but you'll see
why I stick to my guns I know I'm the
same person all the time and some people
like to hear the truth and some people
like you to blow smoke up their ass and
she's with a little smoke flower she's a
little smoky yeah Joe she likes a little
smoke well speaking of Joe yes another
major news story that I'm personally
devastated about a bassoon is a judge
has decided to deport Joe Giudice after
he serves time in prison um Melissa when
we spoke to her which to interview comes
out on Monday
she said the family's working on some
sort of appeal but have you spoken to
Teresa
uh I've texted with Teresa we haven't
actually spoken I just told her I'm here
for her I give her my support and
whatever she needs from me what are your
thoughts my thoughts are it's
devastating the most devastating in
housewives history and just you know
she's been dealt very bad blows and
she's the strongest woman I know and
we'll deal with it accordingly she
really she really is like so strong yeah
I mean Barry what's still upsetting
about it it's like she went to prison
and then Joe had to go through prison it
was like these five years of torture and
it's like finally we can get out of the
tunnel and live our lives but now known
avatars are just begins yeah it's like
it's a bad thing he's further than
prison or would be further than prison
if he is deported but yes yeah it's a
it's very upsetting it's just you know
what she's taking a lot of blows her
family's taking a lot of blows but if
anybody can handle adversity it's true
she's so strong mm-hmm I didn't see it
but apparently Danielle was on Wendy
Williams and had something to say about
you do you see it and what did she say
recap yes she told me to stay in my lane
Oh Madame marriage what yeah I was like
but she was just very upset saying I'm
kind of like you know not a girl's girl
and I was like you know what it's not
even about being girl's girl I'm a
person for Humanity I'm a human and yes
and it's not about that I just stand up
for what's right
regardless man woman child animal as
well you should as that's just the way I
roll where do you guys go for trips this
season besides Bimini for the wedding
obviously we go I can't you know well I
can we go to cabo go to cabo yes
margaritas for everyone so we don't be
late for margarita
yes margarita margarita and we go to
Oklahoma and we go to Oklahoma believe
it or not wait Oklahoma which is the
twist of one of my best friends so
that's a trend is it like Ranchi buddies
Holly Wilson yes Ranchi vibes ranching
behind your cattle oh my god boys cattle
and cowboys that's amazing when we spoke
to Melissa you told us her house is for
sale and she's thinking about moving to
LA yeah I'm not gonna let her oh thank
you thank you I'm like Melissa you were
not going that way oh right
so New Jersey she so I think she just
says that to torture me okay yeah to
torture us yeah so we beg her to stay
okay
she wants us to what everyone refer to
us yeah I'm like what are you thinking
you don't know okay good what about
marchini or how's she doing Marcy is
amazing she was just away visiting a
boyfriend in Florida well we got a lot
of questions is she dating yes she is
definitely dating it was a couple people
scary she was in Florida and it was
right by that a little yoga thing I mean
the restaurant right near though it's
does to get marks in your text may wait
what he'll be there was a shooting there
was a shooting very scary horrible
horrible but no but Marcia she knows
okay Tamar singer is okay but it was
this is Marge singers taking on she was
so upset about she's like see I told you
I shouldn't do yoga that's why I see her
that's her reason why she's not gonna do
yoga how did she meet her man I think
this is an old boyfriend from a long
time ago Marcia likes to revisit the
page
and everybody good if someone serviced
her well the first time she's going back
for more are we gonna see a lot more of
marching on the show this yes in this
season you see a lot of Marge singer a
lot of Marge stamp you know that we
deserve yes what that's what we deserve
yeah that's the content we need to be
surveying yeah we need to new housewives
did you know either of them before they
came on Jackie and so she comes on as
your friend yeah she comes on as my
friend she's a mute she was a mutual
friend of someone else it's that like
hard I feel like I mean technically
didn't ciggy you came on Ziggy's friend
we were we were acquaintances singing
our were acquaintances we were never
like BFFs because you can see that we're
different types of yeah we always enjoy
each other part you know we got a show
together
Jackie and I actually are much more
similar she's sarcastic she's smart
she's a former attorney even though she
is 10 years younger than I am we happen
to get along yeah and she's very easy
and we stay getting along so it's good
so we don't have that issue that's ideal
I feel like there's certain situations
where in housewives history they bring
on a friend and it's like the end of
like Adrienne and Brandi like it's tough
we're not competitively with each other
I'm not a competitive girl I want
everybody to do amazing I wouldn't want
to have a great life I I you know it's
just everything everybody should be
fabulous everybody should look amazing
by the way and yours I celebrate
people's good things you really do like
I feel like we've only known you what
now for like six eight months and you
were just like consistently like so nice
and so thank you always reaching out and
like I learned a like people say things
like that and then they're [ __ ] you
know yes you are tried and true
thank you I love you oh yeah yeah and I
try and I try and say that way and I'm
not saying I can't be a [ __ ] but when
Wendy went right when necessary but then
I back you know her only human only
human being so close to New York I'm
sure that you guys run into a lot of the
New York housewives have events and
other housewives in general who is a
housewife that you have been wanting to
meet that you met that you just like
loved and then also you know someone who
wasn't you don't like the night's lost I
love well I spent time with her and I
got to go to the Berkshires with Dorinda
oh I took her the Berkshire desert house
lovely magnificent she made all right
then you can even see
on TV yes it's really spectacular
Josette's our top three houses he's ever
been to Wow by the pool where during the
summer we went during the summer so Joe
and I had gone up there and it was and
she's lovely and we had the best time
ever
Ramona's great but sometimes she doesn't
yeah she's absolutely hysterical but
sometimes she's like just not in the
mood you know what I mean she's just not
in the mood for me I I understand that
you know so even though we share a
publicist which i think is so funny
she's always going to be but she's
always sometimes just not in the mood
okay so the New York ones we get to be
around I've never met Bethenny were you
team Bethenny or Carol I know do you
know why yeah I just feel like Bethenny
should have just said to Carol you know
what I'm hurt I love you I want to make
up yeah I just wish Bethenny gives a
tough exterior and I say she's very
rough tough creampuff yep I think she's
very soft
yeah she's been through a ton yes and
she's been through a lot so I think she
gives a much rougher exterior and that's
not a reason I'm team Carol it is and by
the way I think Carol has amazing style
I'm a little obsessed with Carol style I
used to be I feel like in prior season
she really was like sensual downtown
yeah then she seriously yeah is that
what it's like she wasn't trying and she
was so cool and then she was like
realize when she tried yeah it was like
when she wasn't trying her
effortlessness was like cool yeah she
realized it was cool so she was
channeling that effort like I know you
mean I know it's not cool anymore but I
still like her pieces like I love the
way she looked on the reunion the
Bethenny killed the Ryu yo top my
favorite look on the rim ever ever I
said give it to our top favorite look I
wanna take questions so I could see
where that outfit me too I'm like a high
pony yes yes beautiful okay this is from
Kyle O'Grady do you have any advice for
a young career woman who's just starting
out in their business if they want to be
an entrepreneur the first thing you have
to know is what you're good at and what
you're not good at Kyle that's what I
say and hire people or even get interns
for what you're not good at because
everybody's not good at everything I
can't be good that's it you cannot be
good at everything
do not go into business with a friend
mmm right away sister what sisters are
okay family's always family that's okay
no but friends it could fall apart
totally I started my business with my
friend all-in minute right now
Macbeth question stars my friend it does
fall apart it's very hard
friends of money and things like that so
if you can't measure yes if you can
avoid going into business with your
friend it's not a good idea
a lot of things retail stinks right now
yeah do not open a retail store so
please if it's anything to your
three-tailed Kyle don't open a retail
store that would not be a good concept
right this very second start on the
Internet
social media is definitely your friend
so definitely do something with social
media to get your brand out there it's
the most inexpensive way to do anything
it's all about marketing and packaging
you could package anything and make it
look amazing I mean look at the pet rock
years ago yes but I'm just saying you
could package it and make it look good
so it's all about the marketing and
everything like that so get I'm sure
you're a young girl but I have all young
people around me and they make me look
good so that's what's about this appends
pearson who are you closest with on the
cast currently and who are you not on
good terms with oh I would say the
closest I'm with is Melissa and really
Jackie and who I'm not really close with
obviously is Danielle yeah who else is
that Dolores and Teresa were good I mean
because Teresa and I are good I mean
Dolores and I our friendship has really
grown but I'd have to say the clothes
Melissa we're together all the time yeah
well do you find it difficult or
Jennifer I'm not that good with Jennifer
I don't want nothing like we we fight we
make up we fight we make up or different
people can be friends with everyone at
times cousin that's a show it's also
it's not real life some people just piss
you off
totally and you're not meant to like
everyone and everyone doesn't have to be
friends yeah what they do week this is
such a good question from Brianna kana
taro Wow do you now get wife's Iggy and
Dolores didn't like Danielle and do you
now feel differently about Ziggy and
Dolores now knowing what you know about
Danielle I can understand why they
didn't like Danielle I never felt ill
about Dolores do I feel differently
about Ziggy now no I had no issue with
Ziggy not liking Danielle it wasn't
about that it was different the reason
is thinking right until one we're
totally different reasons but I totally
had a pilot I apologized to Dolores and
saying I'm very sorry that's not that I
didn't believe you so now you believe
Dolores about what happening outside I
do sir I think Danielle her perception
what she likes to say she twists the
twist
what she hears yes in a way you say it
is not how she repeats it back to you
right I think that's a very common issue
yeah with everyone like yes especially
it's bad camera time especially on
housewives yes yes this is from May
space 13 they say after watching your
first season did your kids reach out to
you after watching or did they watch my
I know my kids had watched the first
season because of course they told my
ex-husband and you told my other side
it's not that they reach out but of
course I always text my kids when I say
my kids my kids are old people don't I
don't think they realize that they
haven't me one happens to be like 40 and
the other ones like 37 so they're grown
adults i text them whatever it was
emotional it was definitely emotional
we're not tight still but it's in the
works that's a positive movement yeah a
positive movement that's great well you
can ask okay that's all I can ask for
I mean I have a long time to live I'm
gonna make it work this is Stefan ik
flurry are you excited to not be like
the new girl anymore it was that tough
for you I'm excited not to be the new
girl I'm excited there's new girls in
and I'm excited I feel like a little
veteran Peggy 4 4 6 6 where can we buy
more of milk collection products oh well
thank god there's a new website coming
and we have a lot of new products coming
out but we sell a lot of big retailers
so we sell the home goods the TJ targets
everybody so we saw so many big
retailers that this stuff goes in and
out very quickly but soon we'll have it
all on the website ok this is final
question page princey
and I think you might have said it the
last time you were here but how and when
and why did the pigtail start tell us
the background sorry it was a Wikipedia
of the pigtails as a little girl my
mother would put me in pigtails by long
hair like you put yeah you know it was
like a good long hair and my mother
would you know just put my hair back in
pigtails and it worked for me as a
little kid it's like a tall Toria net
pigtails so one day I want to do
something hair put big Tosun everyone's
like you look great I got so many
compliments you look fabulous I was like
wow this is like you need to hear stuff
and then my husband's like he's so
bankable in those big toe she looks so
bad well I was like you know what and
then people got I got known for it in
business so dough is where they go oh
powerhouse with pigtails tease me you
know oh the girl in pigtails and it made
me different it made me stand out if I
walked into a room I was very recognized
the boss like you know what it works on
me and this is so good hair you know
when I said gosh you
three hands and a pigtails it works
something no I love how long have you
been rocking the pigtails now I'm old so
like 30 years yeah they've people have
seen me in it so as a little girl took a
break for a while went back to it I
think that's awesome I think you have a
sense it does and I do different
hairstyles all time I do the high pony
the pigtails had a baby they turn into a
pony
they conjoined I do that I'm sometimes
I'm powerhouse in a pouf I'd like to
change my hair I'd like to change my
hair yeah who doesn't
I do consistently still wear pigtails
it's nice to have a consistent look that
you are happy with yes it's nice and
easy
I know whether it's so easy uniformity
uniform it's a it's a uniform and it
works but I'd like to do all different
looks I'm a little community and I'm
always in costume you are when'd you
guys from the reunion Jane I'm not sure
do you know do you know what you're
gonna wear yet no where you go about
taking early the process is there's
always like a little theme to the
reunion and I always like to do
something dramatic I just feel like I've
been to chali wood vibe you just in my
head vintage Hollywood Marshalls
definitely realized yes in real life so
I always feel like I'm going with a
vintage Hollywood book last year I wore
green so I probably will not wear green
this year okay I'm not gonna be beaded
ChaCha like a lot some people know
Giovanni for you I'm not saying no job
because Giovanni does have some
beautiful yeah I know Giovanni they're
hard to get really nice you could go
back to the showroom okay well I try and
I am the toast is a springboard if you
want something happen where you've
received that's your destiny
I would like to Giovanni invitation to
the showroom you could go a lot of
weddings coming up yeah I go right up to
tehrani which Taurani gives me my
dresses also the shopping you could go
yeah see I'm sure you could go right up
to tehrani
I set it up I could I could set that up
in twos that guy but yeah so I will be
wearing something I would like to wear
I'm just putting out there right now
Michael Costello hello yes I liked I'd
like to wear something with big arms
okay so cuz I think that could be very
dramatic I don't like this long it
should be like whacked somebody in the
head but I like long I look amongst down
I'm always very look I mean I don't have
the good likes that little pokey same
say it out saying you're here I know
he's like but you know if you have to
put him we're okay yeah that's all that
matters and we do by the way oh yeah I
love you Margaret Cho says we know we
ran over and that you have a million
things to do so we can't thank you
enough for stopping by our look at you I
love you girls and I mean just I'm sorry
you girls are so successful so fabulous
and people should emulate the two of
these girls because they're amazing and
everyone keep it with March where they
probably want Instagram at the real
market right real Margaret justice on
instagram at the macbeth collection oh
my dog the real bella panic now i'm
gonna be at sabotage play day yes we
have to set up a drug you play 100%
Thank You Marge thank everyone for
having toast the Millennial morning show
we go live Monday through Friday 10:30
a.m. Eastern Time on Facebook and
YouTube so make sure you are subscribe
to all those pages we're also available
at spot casts on Spotify and iTunes
thank you so much for being here we will
see you tomorrow
you